what are you most looking forward to the
next two years the next four years
getting done
honestly you know one thing I pride
myself in my history is be able to get
stuff done and not just talk about it
and we laid out a very
we laid out a very aggressive agenda
tonight it's going to take a lot of work
and a lot of cooperation and
Partnerships and fiscal responsibility
and how are you going to do that though
with Democrats in control of this
building and you're a member of a
different party I think that's the big
question by doing it together
communicating together and having
conversations nobody should ignore
either side of the aisle
that's how we're gonna do it